probably the most highly anticipated
video game comes out next Tuesday
November 4th I'm talking about Call of
Duty advanced warfare this is something
a lot of people are talking about now
even though Call of Duty is not out yet
this is incredible I got a chance to
play an advanced copy of the game and it
was amazing now legally I am not allowed
to show any actual gameplay footage just
yet I'm allowed to show it next week but
I'm not allowed to show it this week but
I can show you a sneak preview of my
honest reaction to the game came to the
right maybe they're cops
oh my god was awesome oh that was the
greatest feeling I've ever experienced
and I've watched two of my children
before playing people outside I was
playing the game in this room and people
that work on the staff watch me come out
of the room and I was just drenched in
sweat
I needed a cigarette it was incredible
if you want to see my review of the new
Call of Duty before it hits the stores
tune in next Monday night we're gonna
show everything needs to be a lot of fun
you